giá Trung cư tăng trong mặt, sách mở sử bụng nhá của người chẻ tại vì ăn chở nên sà vời.
Và năm chở này đầy, thì chương mắt đồng sạm ở mi ăn, tặc biệt là phân cục chung cư tại thành phố viên,
chính kiến tình trạng giá thỏ lẻ tăng trong mặt. Điều này, khiến sức mở sử bụng nhá của người lâu đậu,
đặc biệt là các xa đình chẻ cho nên sà vời hơi bà dù hết, đến nay thì vì ăn có hơn chứ mưa dự ăn chung cư
cũng ứng ra tịch trường khoảng vui bệnh gình cân hộ. Thuy nhiên, có sự ngày vẫn chưa đặc ứng lũi cầu nhá ở của người dân,
đặc biệt là tại thành phố viên, với tất loại lâu thì hỏa khoảng 2,5% mặt năm,
xanh sống tại chúng tâm thành phố viên vượt mất người chụng người, bài tỏa nhá ử, đặc biệt là các tàn hộ chung cư nhỏ có,
tệ nghi, phố hộ phếm mục đích sử dụng của các xa đình chẻ, ngày còn chở nên các thiết,
tại thế giới các đầy ba năm, xa chúng cư chành địa bàn thành phố viên chỉ dây vọng khoảng 12.5% mặt vong,
thì đến đau năng ai ngàn công trọng hay bà, xa cán hộ chung cư có thương tăng,
có tăng lực để tưởng năng ai ngàn công trọng hay để tự cho đến nay,
hiện, căn hộ chung cư năng ở phân cốc lình dân, danh có mục xa to đậu từ 12.5% mặt vong,
con cốc khóc lên để thay môi đến ba mê làm chựa đồng bó bất vong,
một dù giá pháp đường xam thắc ca đoạn chung cư lâu tháng là vậy,
thuy nhiên quà cỏa sáp thì con cũng có kỳ.
Thuy nhiên quà cỏa thất, thuy nhiên quà cỏa sáp thì con không theo kỳ cầu,
đơn cử, xa các cân hộ chung cư cầu cấp trên đường quan trung,
là thứ 2 mì mốt đến hai mì hai chựa đồng bất vong,
thời điểm là hãi ngàn công trọng hay bì mốt, đến nay đã tăng lên hơn ba mê chựa đồng bó bất vong,
hai như giữa ám chung cư nằm trên đường phân bộ châu, thời điểm bử dây vụ sây vụ sông phần thô,
đang trong quá trình hình địch những tham đã đặt chỗ hết bởi mức xa trên hai mùi chựa đồng bất vong,
mức truyên ra bất lực sản nhận địch, xa tất loại trung cư ở mi ăn sẽ tiếp tục
là thăm tự nay cho đến xam là thay đàn công trọng hay bí lăng, xong mồn côn mối ngày càng nhận sọng,
trong khi đó, xong khi sắp nực thì giá cơ lỏ và bốn xa tụi kể gây lộp,
thì như cầu nhà ở tại thành phố viên lại tiếp tục tăng cao.